è passato davvero parecchio tempo
dall'ultima volta che ho fatto ha
chinato e mi avete detto che è molto
molto semplice ormai indovinare gli
youtubers robe del genere da parte di a
pineto quindi ragazzi sono qua per
provare un'altra volta e vedere che
succede proviamo a pensare a liste a chi
netto per chi non lo conoscesse ma state
fuori dal mondo se non lo conoscete
questo genio quindi non è pietro che
indovina che cosa stai pensando quindi
se provo a pensare a me stesso
pensiamo a fa vj ha più di 35 anni nova
il suo personaggio diventato famoso
grazie alla terza domanda alla terza
domanda ha già capito si ha a che fare
con mondi videogiochi si è daltonico no
è un bagni un bagnino avrebbe già dovuto
indovinare però in quanto non so ogni
c'è nella vasca da bagno xi però non nel
resto del mondo
no so parte dei mesi no a che fare con
fa vj non ne sono sicuro dove mettiamo
sia giocato del como
questo è scemo indossa sempre delle
cuffie no a che fare con firenze no dai
mari inizia una mano della sindone è due
ore per sapevo andata il suo domando ha
indovinato i continui il passaggio è
stato ed è già stato indovinato 391mila
635 volte quindi ragazzi a questo punto
siccome mi domanda numero murlo il suo
passaggio
grazie a youtube si bye bye bye bye
basta basta abbiamo capito tex tempi di
uscita dal caso ci sto pensando a
lorenzo su sto pensando a lorenzo studio
riuscita a foto di sterling visto che è
diventato molto semplici dominare gli
youtubers siano un qualcosa di fitch e
pensiamo ai genitori degli youtube spese
pronto a mio padre
il suo personaggio è stato scoperto
grazie a youtube mettiamo sì anche se
una nota
faremo dei videogiochi no è femmina no
al nome di nizza per l stai tentando di
indovinare me comunque canta tutto molto
interessante no grazie a dio
attualmente più di trent'anni si ciesco
marito aspetto googlare ho pensato a mio
padre non ha dominato cesco omar e non è
mio padre non è cesco mare così abiti da
cerimonia no canta in dialetto no ad 20
30 anni quaranta misti esisterebbero si
mio padre forse la presa sul serio se
cosa dentro per il suo padre di pochi j
si 53 mila volte che che pensa a mio
padre 53 mila volte mi devo preoccupare
beh a questo punto giochiamo pensiero a
mia madre mia madre dai il terzo
tentativo in italia si è avuto figli si
è donna si è una nonna non è una nonna
con figlio famosi ha un figlio che ha
tanti amici sì comunque a che fare con
fa vj ha indovinato mia madre non ci
credo lavoravo ipantellas che io sappia
no mamma se pensano di più a mia a mia
madre ho mio palla di sì
18.000 volta pensano di più a mio padre
prolunga e grave sta roba 18mila persone
che pensano a mia madre tra cui gabry
ponte ma trizio e adesso abbiamo pensato
a persone che mi sono vicine che quindi
vanno che siano nella mia vita invece
adesso pensiamo a persone che mi stanno
sul cazzo pietro è diventato famoso
grazie
si vabbè va a un cane di videogiochi si
adora rossonero idea e non mi interessa
parte dei makes no ha giocato nel como
no è fissato per la polizia ma va puzza
pure no abbia faremo famiglie si fuma
marijuana
sì però mettiamo noi gas adri cuffie fa
video con le cuffie cm non so però che
si fa sentire
e per forza di cose marito andò a per
gli ho dato una chiusa
no no no mi paragona russa quello io no
a chi sta pensando a quel maniaco di
pietro in via maniaco conferme abile
bene hai dominato mia madre mio padre
pietro no come possibile anche vari
progetti si indossa delle cuffie
mettiamo no perché secondo me la gente
pensa che sono lo collega troppo a me di
da milano si vicino perse un membro
della sua band
no è un gamer si è stato il primo
presidente nero il suo personaggio è
stato il primo presidente nero cosa mi
rappresenta questa domanda ha la barba
no con tatuaggio se che non lo so non
credo davvero che foto poi 1593 volte
mio padre e mia madre sono pensati
milioni di volte in più di pietro che
siamo qualcosa difficilissimo ivy e
cleverbot indossa abiti maschili no non
so se indovinerà mai croci provoli di
nazionalità italiana no ha una sorella
no ai capelli se esiste davvero no è
femmina si combatte no e giapponese sono
giappone viene da internet si è un robot
si è un computer seguente so se un robot
che cosa devo rispondere sì amy è volto
comedy non avendo né a trevi e 1.750
l'altro volte sempre comunque indovinato
più volte di pietro va bè ragazzi aveva
pensato a mio padre mia madre pietro e
via
pensiamo alla mia versione tamarra
lorenzo non so se il dovi non penso però
vabbè valente ai proviamoci si maschio
si rientrato musica del calcio vorresti
è più di 35 anni no ma siamo lì zio mi
piace così morto è un eroe nella bibbia
al nome di sorelle si è mai apparso in
una trasmissione di barbara d'urso
questo non lo so glielo devo chiedere
perché la tronista
dovevo dire questi va napoli no
valentino bisegna a tanti scritti su
youtube no
lorenzo amico di parigi abbiamo detto
che non c'è neanche la folla sì sì e lui
comunque 32 volte ho trovato con un meno
pensato di pietro che sia giusto che
credi via sta roba è una roba
difficilissima che non indovinerà tipo
il personaggio di audire nato in italia
no ai capelli se non me lo ricordo
[Musica]
no all'aspetto di un animale no ma cosa
sto weber del cartone no è visibile sì a
entrambi gli occhi si fa parte il
videogioco si fa parte del videogioco
filemaker frank thies immaginate ad ogni
versione fai un bel freinet 3 disk è
brutto mi chiedevano farlo assolutamente
dunque no è cattivo si è famoso grazie a
minecraft anche su minecraft a oris
sarebbe raccapricciante al posto degli
zombie cammina su due gambe si fa parte
del genere horror
se pesa più di cento che cazzo ne so
mica lo ha pesato secondo me si vive in
un appartamento no una casa bo crossa e
un nuovo alla coda no e blu si fa parte
di armi se la ride blu demon sì comunque
1994 volte sempre più volte di pietro
non mi ricordavo che fosse così forte a
chi network steve di fp uil e femmina no
è l'inazione da tenera no è veramente
esistito no ai capelli di videogioco si
usa le pistole no ai baffi non credo che
steve aveva fino a combattere la spada è
nel world group e ron o di base e
cattivo no combatte no a un cellulare
giocare qui non è che gioca per lui è in
sé ping con cui si dà e nonno non è non
lo schalke zio ha un vestito rosso dio
mio che l'ha preso ma come può prendere
qualsiasi cosa quest'uomo si comunque ha
mai provato faremo aggiunge spesso la
maglietta rosa me l'hai chiesto prima se
sei scemo cioè l'alzheimer devo dire sì
mica potete mettere un immagine più
piccola vero steve df wheels indovinato
sempre più volte di pietro comunque su
motori dca personaggi sui motori dreams
questo non me lo può mai azzeccare nella
vita gioca non me lo può mai a giocare
con il suo motore di una linea non è
neanche un uomo cioè alla pelle no puzza
da quella era pietro 0 di chiedere prima
fa parte videogioco si sa che fare col
clash royale no immaginate se flash
royale quando trovate la carta dice
motori dell'ingv di sciami che vanno a
combattere la torretta alle gambe si ma
non sa usarle agli occhi chiari non ci
ha gli occhi e vissuti nostrane no cosa
del suo meglio di novartis ha giocato a
che fare con le armi no sto pensando
asso volato al risposto no a tutto ed è
uscito su motorini reeves come è
possibile
raga io ci ho pensato anche i giochi
abbastanza non sconosciuti ma quale ci
voglio dire se pensa lo slider meno
indovina subito per dire mi piacciono
motori dreams come aveva preso posso
pensare qualsiasi cosa non so il cane
lidl a sapri gamer zarco c'è veramente
sto pensando a zacco i canali di sabrina
è scoperto grazie a youtube sia che poi
abbiamo di videogiochi no ha lavorato
con belen del cane fa parte di me la
godo il cane di sabrina no alla
pelliccia bianca no napoli no di milano
sicura dove tesi zago come madri carne
di sabrina c'è chi è veramente nuova
misura di malori
allora perché l'ho già fatta di netto un
paio di volte ma non pensavo mi
ricordavo così forte minchia incredibile
così il dominatore infinitamente più di
pietro tra l'altro i miei capelli
esiste davvero purtroppo si vede amici
no io li odio no a che fare con gesù se
me li faccio crescere tanto si ha un
gemello no fa parte dei mesi non che io
sappia no poi il nostro se avete fatto
di testa vostra che farebbe fare jesse
ha avuto problemi con la legge secondo
me volevano arrestarmi una volta perché
o di capelli strani però non hanno
potuto no era un divo dei film muti e sì
perché quando ti guardi rimane a bocca
aperta al prego la grande bellezza no
pietro cava pietro nola pietro o ci sono
ci ho messo un'ora non far indovinare
un'ora mi ha fatto pensare i miei
capelli di omini non impossibile ragazzi
basta c'è veramente se giocano assurdo
cioè incredibile ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto come momento io vi piace
anche per riscattare comino tutta la
svizzera non sapersi chiede lcd vediamo
un prossimo video bella ragazzi e
comunque mi capelli sono meno indovinati
di pietro
[Musica]